il va arriver dans la salle il va rouler
dans la salive arrivée dans la salle
stressant soulageant stressant et
soulageant ça y est il est là ce beau
défi ce beau défi on y est arrivé
en fait la suite tous les médias de
râler en salle de presse puisque on a
voulu faire la conférence de presse
avant qu'il ait effectivement sa
rencontre avec les jeunes donc ils
puissent être plus disponible pour les
jeunes après et qui détermine si tu peux
si nous c'est moi qui n'a été menée
puisque c'est le référent un média donc
de l'organisation avec elle et c'est
avec son agent tant que ce soit optimisé
le plus opérationnel possible sur tu te
retrouves en relation de test oui et oui
déjà promise
non non je connais pas la réunion mais
moi je suis un don meehan chien ni loi
quand on m'a proposé ce projet j'ai dit
oui parce que la réunion je vais
apprenez que de loin j'ai deux
appartements ici je n'ai jamais vu
g j'ai énormément de réunionnais en
équipe de france
dont matthieu daffreville je pense que
vous le connaissez le projet tellement
bien ficelé et tellement beau et
tellement alléchant parce que venir à la
réunion
faire quelques opérations avec la salle
des associations avec les instances avec
le club et des données de savoir moi
c'est des choses que j'aime et en plus à
la réunion donc c'est un plaisir et
c'est un honneur parfois c'est pas comme
ça je vous le dire c'est la fouge su
bousculer je comprends mais parfois
c'est très lisse et là pour l'instant
tout va bien vous êtes le seul problème
c'est l'appui
on m'a dit qu'il était très bon
j'espère bien son mal raconté quand m
même ambiance aussi
pour voir un athlète exceptionnel donné
un très bon exemple mon fils dans la vie
voilà et c'est un athlète très rare
c'est un bon exemple c'est un parfait
exemple de réussite c'est un il est
multi champion du monde cette fois
champion du monde c'est rarissime
gentil
la taille de la potiche
première des énergies à leur arc pas
impressionnant déjà de voir tous ces
gens qui se place comme un revenu ça va
ça me fait plaisir
superbe accueil que j'ai pu découvrir le
son des îles ici donc voilà que du court
a que des bons moments j surpasser
encore énormément de bons moments comme
ça en tout cas voilà les grands sur les
jeunes sont contents donc c'est
l'essentiel
il me dit quoi
bonjour
tu l'as dit bonjour et il t'a dit quoi
faire ou pas
comment maple fort que toi